guys it may seem like the fake guru
scene started a couple years ago here in
my garage but in fact people like ty
Lopez did not innovate anything people
think ty Lopez is like the grandpappy of
you know Hagar is no incorrect
they were looking back back before all
coffee Zilla was even a twinkle in the
eye did we're looking back to 1991 to a
true granddaddy of fake gurus to mr. Tom
foo now you're gonna learn a few things
in this video number one literally
nothing about the fake guru pitch has
changed like if you think a guy on the
TV or internet or screen saying hey I'm
gonna make you rich if you just give me
money if you think that's new well I
just want to be the first to introduce
you to Tom vu because he ran a real
estate scheme back in the day he's now a
retired guru you know he's aged out now
that the new gurus are in right but back
in the day the guy really selling get
rich was Tom vu baby and he was crushing
it crushing it and let's just let's just
fire up one of his ads this program is a
paid advertisement for personal
advancement Institute incorporated now
the first thing to notice okay first of
all hey you should treat this whole
thing as like a webinar it's the TV
version of a webinar was an infomercial
back in the day secrets a success and
just tell me if you think that anything
has changed from then to now watch
indies we already got the yacht what was
your new year resolution most people
just talk about it are you going to make
it happen
real estate remind you of anyone
we're actually flying back here i had to
charter a jet fly back from the
Berkshire Hathaway meeting with Warren
Buffett it's like a Thai Lopez
commercial the expert Tom vu on how to
make a fortune in the 90s a lot of
people in America are wealthy filthy
rich do what do the girls have to do
with with personal wealth I know what
they have to do with this video but
imagine you're back in the 90s dude and
Tom who pops on this TV dude and he's
telling you just show up to my free
seminar
self-made millionaire Tom vu has taught
thousands how to achieve financial
freedom again we could be present-day
right now looking at a any kind of
seminar it's just all gone online now
richest people make their fortune in
real estate isn't it about time for you
to learn how tom booze real estate
investing seminar has been written up by
many newspapers across North America
again once again nothing's changed
people pay for PR that's how they get
put in the newspaper now people are
paying to get into Forbes same exact
business model just siphon a bunch of
poor people's money did from Quebec to
Miami I started with nothing and I found
a way to make a fortune in real estate
I've been showing thousands of people
trust this guy how he made his fortune
is selling you on selling real estate if
you want to learn how to make good deals
like this come and see Tom vu honestly
you know it's crazy about this is that I
like this ad better than most the
webinars I see like I guess my thesis
going into this was that nothing's
changed in webinars and infomercials and
fake guru strategies but honestly I
would say but if you take away the bad
camera quality and just look at like the
commercial infomercial itself he's doing
a better job than all the gurus today
it's like they're getting worse at their
job cuz this I mean pretty high
production value here Tom I know a lot
of you may say if Farmville making so
much money in real estate
why is he teaching seminar oh this is
good this is good yeah every every guru
has to answer this question and they
never seem to answer it that well but
let's let's hear Tom out let's hear tom
has a better answer than our standard
I'm helping because I care well someday
you a multi-millionaire you have a lot
of choices to spend your day today I
have a lot of choices to spend the day
today I could go yachting from Florida
to the Caribbean having fun today I
could relax enjoy live around my mention
watching the waterfall on the front the
waterfall in the back oh no he did he
never addresses the women I love it
enjoy live around my mention watching
the water
the front washing the waterfall in the
front I'm sure that's what you're
watching Tom the waterfalls just filming
the girl back the fool look like the lik
waterfall inside the house oh gosh this
is amazing I got tired of hearing the
water running Oh think about this this
was airing on television guys if you
think the FTC is gonna come in and stop
these gurus think about it they haven't
stopped them for literally over 27 years
28 I don't know however many years has
been since 1991 29 years they're not
gonna do jack dead they're not doing
jack for you guys you guys who get
scammed by these people they're not
gonna change one thing why because
you're poor and poor people's problems
don't get a lot of attention it's just
the way it is I mean you could argue
about it but that's life so you got to
address you got to just live with the
fact that these fake gurus they're gonna
continue to exist and you have to
protect yourself from these this type of
scam you need to recognize any time you
see this same formula the formula that
literally has not changed for 29 years
just hey I'm out when they start talking
about the waterfall in the back that's
how you know you're about to get
railroaded okay for a lot of money today
I can do it oh sorry I don't let's back
up a little bit the phone we're hearing
about why he does why he does seminars
to get back to it look like the lik
waterfall inside the house I got tired
of hearing the water running or today I
can do something that gave me the
greatest personal satisfaction that even
money couldn't buy he's showing people
how to be rich come on Tommy Boy give me
a break dude that's look he pretty good
actor so far that's bad acting cuz I
don't believe him for one second and
neither do you
he's got tired of the waterfall running
right he got tired of this waterfall
running right house I got tired of
hearing the water running oh I got tired
of here honey
but I love to see you succeed which is
why I want you to pay for my course the
Kommetjie does this he's really trying
to get you to believe it I can do
something that gave me the greatest
personal satisfaction that even money
couldn't buy he's showing people how to
be rich
I because I can relate to you a certain
amount of you are watching me right now
are working so hard you're willing to
pay the price of success you're willing
to sweat but you've got nothing because
you like a vehicle to achieve financial
independence yeah boy yeah he's just
like you Tom vu
mr. waterfall dude he's just like he's a
man of the people dude he's a man of the
people he understands your situation
it's a go when I first fact that out on
my son's the wealth I wish there was a
multi-millionaire I wish I had a mentor
ever heard that one before I wish I just
wish I had a mentor which is why I want
to be your mentor for thousands of
dollars he starts to so we're not gonna
watch this whole thing obviously but up
more women he talks about you know I
used to be a poor fella to our free
seminar where he upsells you into his
expense of course and eventually guys in
1991 he gets basically busted by Inside
Edition these guys were copies illa
before copies illa we we weren't a thing
we didn't even have a single view at
this point in time right and they're
already busting gurus and today there
are more gurus than ever which goes to
show you that Inside Edition well nobody
listened to them ever dream of living in
a house like this it's no dream for Tom
who you think I'm at the Country Club no
no no this is my house this is my tennis
court this is one out of the dude this
reminds me so much of a Thai Lopez ad if
you've been failing a lot in life I feel
your pain cuz I've been there to confuse
I don't know which guy I went to bribe
what counter you won the drive right and
you dream of oh yeah have a good guy
you've got no way I get my friend look
at the toys are here points at the girl
again look at my waterfall right there
hey which waterfall do I Drive hard to
drive I got confused I don't know which
guy I went to bribe this is like such a
next-level play right you get all these
hot girls and your your your
advertisements and then you don't even
address him his lawyer says it's not
fair to say Tom vu was selling a scheme
to get rich quick but listen to how Tom
boo himself describes what he's Hawking
them I call it the Tom Ville put money
making system and his lawyer says it's
not a get-rich-quick scheme
Tom boo I call it the quick money-making
system
oh well you can't make this stuff up and
this is where all those people say they
all say in their ad on the one hand oh
yeah hey if this if you want to get rich
quick scene this is not a get-rich-quick
scheme and then in the in the video
they're like let me show you my quick
money-making system I've been fixing
this system all over the country in the
last five years
he's pocketed cash from thousands of
people by persuading them his secrets of
success can lead anybody from rags to
riches just by buying and selling real
estate the Tom vu way he says you don't
need money you don't need credit you
don't even need a college degree
he says he can teach you to make
millions starting from nothing the same
way he did a lot of people say hey if he
can't do it I can do it
I guess what 99 will not do it will
never do it those are the real facts oh
that's a coffee Zelo line hey let's go
stole my line hired this man to help
teach but he says it was Tom vu who
talked students into forking over big
tuition fees even when some of them
could ill afford it absolutely false
there's not a single person that would
ever come to me and say this is the last
time that I ever had and I say go to the
seminar well I remember one student from
from Toronto so Elmo remembers a man
desperate to save his struggling Pizza
franchise he says to Tommy told me the
story says Tom my last 10,000 whatever
the fee was at that time I have it under
the corner of my carpet my living room
should I take it and give it to you
because that's the last penny I have and
you told him to go get the money and
sign up for the Tom
seminar true or not true false
absolutely false dad
these people are sociopaths how could
you know it's amazing it's like
confronting these guys with evidence
they're just like nah hey it didn't
happen and then they cut to the guy
who's like no it definitely happened
there's at this time this guy this pizza
place yeah it happened and they're like
hey Tom we have all the receipts right
here he's like no they're like but Tom
we've got here's the pizza from the
failing pizza shop we got it all
no no didn't happen absolutely not I say
no Tom answered yes go on to the carpet
take the money why does Elmo saying that
why did you believe in somebody like
that I he knows who it is I have plenty
of people who are saying plenty of
things just like that take the isolated
case one at a time my friend
booth oh there's a lot to unpack there
but there that's the first coffee Zillah
insider right that's a coffin Silla
insider that came poured is like this
guy's a scam they used it as evidence
Tom vu Tom it was like no that didn't
happen and the guy's like hey I've got a
bunch of other insiders and Tommy was
like one one person at a time my friend
who says Elmo is disgruntled because he
was fired but anyone who goes to hear
Tom boo can tell you this he said right
at the seminar itself if you have to
sell something to come do it if you have
to mortgage your house do it a lot of
people don't have the guts to learn how
to get rich my friend
don't have the guts to learn how to get
rich you deserve to be poor
[Music]
Caleb Maddox
Caleb Maddox poor I like how he says my
friends a lot my friend if you are trich
you deserve to be poor Hey
if you're poor you deserve to be poor if
you can't scam people you deserve to be
poor if you can't take the last dime out
of a starving child hand take away their
last little Campbell's chicken noodle
soup that they have to their name hey
you just don't deserve to be rich you
don't you don't deserve waterfalls like
this two days sessions in your hometown
cost fifteen hundred bucks but this is
the program Tom vu really wants you to
buy into his week-long real estate boot
camp where he says you can really learn
to be a success 19 people did it just
last week despite the $16,000 tuition
per student Hey
16 grand 19 people let's do that math
real quick on what old Tommy Boy was
making yeah I'm sure he was making all
his money from real estate right he just
wants to help you out only reason he
just gets so much personal satisfaction
let's see how much personal satisfaction
he got right nineteen people times
16,000 baby oh I feel that personal
satisfaction don't you that feels very
personally satisfying oh man
the greatest success is is yours 19
students in this class $16,000 apiece
that's $300,000 in one week I didn't
even have to do the math that is a very
very low price to pay for my time and my
expertise now they are you getting the
picture this is the exact same system
that people are using today I mean
change what they're teaching right
they're not teaching real estate anymore
they're teaching Amazon FBA it's all the
same it's the same exact formula just 29
years later higher def cameras the same
rented equipment property etc and you
know Tom vu he's just he's long gone
right he's just one of many snake oil
salesmen now he's a
he got sued but he settled out of court
and now he just lives fine he's in Vegas
now just to being a professional poker
player that's what he does and I don't
say that to glorify what he does I say
it to say that if you're expecting and
waiting for the ball to drop on these
gurus hey don't hold your breath
all right don't hold your breath on this
industry getting crackdown on what you
got to do you got to laugh at it and you
got to inform your friends right you got
a friends don't let friends go to a Tom
vu seminar and by Tom who I mean any of
these guys right there all the same dude
when you see a Thai Lopez Eddie you
should see a Tom vu ad you should just
take its Tom vu in a white dudes
clothing right he's just he's hiding in
there somewhere you know when you see a
Dan Lockett it's Tom vu you know 20 when
you see Dan lock just Tom vu when you
see Kevin David it's just Tom vu they're
all just Tom vu in different skin suits
and it's just Tom vut wonder neat
they're saying my friend if you deserve
to be poor if you're not if you're not
rich you deserve it before we found only
one out of ten ever made enough money to
even pay off their seminar expenses oh
that's a bad number but what does Tom
you have to say about this nine out of
ten failure rate probably the same thing
that all these givers have to say but
the nine out of ten who cares
hey nobody cares about those nine out of
ten they're just eight have you seen my
waterfall hey it's a very special
waterfall and that's the reason you want
to be rich like me cuz you'll get a
waterfall very nice waterfall I'm sick
guys that's pretty much all I wanted to
show you today this is not a new
phenomenon it did not start with Tai
Lopez any you know nothing's changed
since then really except the
distribution method of tricking young
stupid dumb people to fork over their
money fork over the last dime get a
mortgage at second mortgage on the house
to pay for the seminar it's all the same
nothing's changed and uh yeah I'll see
you guys later
[Music]
never shoulda tried
[Music]
or the car
[Music]